we have the NBA Playoffs the top 10
teams in the East and the top 10 in the
west battling it out to see who can come
out on top
which team will go all the way and win
the championship a lot of teams out
already Celtics doing extremely well the
nips barely holding on the Bucks in the
best position right now Hawks trying to
come around to the front they get there
and they take other stuff that you know
they'll fall out on their own Golden
State trying to stay on getting taken
down by a lot of the teams
Nick's still on here they are still
alive
the Nets trying to get ahead of the
Nuggets can they do it
the Grizzlies still doing well also
and the Knicks are gone and golden state
is going the prisons are gone those
Celtics win